Marjorie Taylor Green is a psychotic silverback gorilla. She
doesn't know how to go, "Oh, it wouldn't really be that effective
a use of my time to back down, right, or to fight with Trump
[music] right now." She's a psychotic silverback gorilla. She
just doesn't believe that she thinks that in the very near future
she will be able to attack Donald Trump. She'll be on the winning
side by doing this. I do not believe for a second that she's
actually just saying, "Okay, I'm going to actually I'm going
to go in like I'm just going to go live my life out here in Georgia.
[music]
Okay. I wanted to see if Asmin Gold had any analysis on this.
All right. I feel like he's not going to I feel like the Asmin
Gold analysis is going to be like he's going to have people in
chat tell him what maybe is happening. He's going to go maybe,
possibly.
She's retiring from Congress. Somebody said she's going to run
for president. Could be. Could be. I don't know. Could be. This
was nuts.
So, she goes out and she puts out a video. We're going to watch
the video. You guys ready to see this? So, she's dropping out
of the Senate race. And here's what I think is kind of >> I
still don't have my soundboard. Imagine I hit a soundboard right
there. She's still dropping out of the Senate race. Okay.
All right. I
>> Funny about it. Let me see if I can find it real quick.
Where the [__] did I go? Uh, damn. Where the [__]
is this?
>> Oh god. Did you just see it? >> Dropping out of
the Senate race. And here's what I think is kind of funny about
it. Let me see if I can find it. >> Can I get that? Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. I got to slow down so we get where the
[__] did they go?
>> But I I didn't see that. Listen, that tweet was right
there the whole time. >> Where the [__] is
this? >> Then he's got he's got some tweet from
Destiny he's liked as well. >> And oh my god, I got to
find it here. No. No, that's not >> Are you going to play
the clip of him watching her? Is there a clip of him watching
her? Maybe. >> All right, we got it. We're ready.
>> This might not actually be that good to be honest. I'm
just going to show you that Asminold like doesn't actually follow
this. He's not really, you know, educating himself. He's not
looking into anything. He doesn't really know what he's talking
about ever. But honestly, I'm just preaching the >> got
to her 100%.
So,
somebody got to her 100%. >> She for the longest time was
like a super like big Trump person. She would wear like a Trump
hat in Congress like this. like she was,
you know, she was a big fan of Trump and uh she deviated from
the acceptable line of thought naturally. Now she's a traitor.
>> Here's what I think is kind of funny. So, oh, he's going
to pull up the pension thing.
You're resigning on January 5th, 2026,
a whopping 5 years and two days after being sworn in.
>> This is not weird. I don't know why people are focusing
on the worst part, the dumbest part of this. People are focused
on the absolute stupidest part of this. God damn it.
Um, you're retiring after your pension kicks in. Like everybody
like everybody retires after certain like cut off dates. Hey,
I went to leave a company once and all of my stock vested after,
you know, my stock fully vested after 3 years. When I was planning
to leave at 2 years and 8 months, I didn't stick around or sorry,
I didn't leave. I stuck around for four months to make sure my
RSUs vested.
That's just everybody all the time with everything. Why are you
leaving money on the table? This happens to be the bare minimum
to lock in the taxpayer funded congressional pension for life.
>> It's like no money, too. >> Resigning 2 days after
her congressional pension vests >> and very convenient.
Let's watch.
This is like I I need to take Trump's side. I need something
to talk about other than the Epstein files. Give me a second.
Give me a second. GIVE ME A SECOND. OH, she's retiring with her
pension. Oh my god. Uh, I think it's because her rhetoric makes
it seem like she's personally invested and pointing at the pension
makes her look more like a grifter, but the pension's not a tangible
amount of money for her. I think the pension's basically nothing,
right? Am I crazy? I thought the pension was basically almost
nothing.
>> The video bag secured. It seems that
Here we go. >> Hi, everyone. >> Hi. I've always represented
the common American man and woman as a member of the House of
Representatives, which is why I've always been despised in Washington
DC. Just never
>> I think her parents owned a construction company that's
like not that didn't do as well. People say she failed at it.
Okay. And then somebody said she g she like basically scammed
a whole bunch in crypto. She probably was involved in Trumpcoin
or something with World Liberty Financial. I'm guessing made
like a whole bunch.
Your net worth wasn't 20 million. It would be meaningful.
It would be. Yeah. But I think it's I don't think it's like huge.
It's like 17k a year. It's like not nothing.
Um minimum Congress pension pension amount is a formula based
calculation not fixed on a minimum dollar value
salary. So
remember retiring at 62 with the minimum five years of service.
The calculation would be this. Hold on. It's over. So like there
is she hasn't served for that long. She's got $8,700 a year.
Probably the bigger deal, I'm guessing, is I think you get benefits
for life. Am I wrong on that? I think that would be a bigger
deal if that's the case, is I think you get health care benefits
for life. Like whatever the congressional healthare plan is,
I think you get to stay enrolled in that for life.
That's probably worth more than the actual money she's getting.
>> So anyway, >> never fit in, >> Americans
are used by the political industrial complex of both. >> That's
like the same thing with the NFL. I know in the NFL that's always
a big one is you get the NFL health care for the rest of your
life which you need cuz your brain is destroyed. So if you don't
make it to like the pension for the NFL which I think is like
3 years or something you're like you're really you and that was
a big thing with CTE when they did all those investigations.
They're trying to get people like permanent healthcare. Like
if you play one snap in the NFL you just get permanent healthcare
for life or something along those lines. both political parties
election cycle after election cycle in order to elect whichever
side can convince Americans to hate the other side more
>> to make it through the second contract I think. Yeah,
that's a long time. So, three years I think your rookie >> No,
this is what happens is that I'm going to explain how how how
it works. So, basically you're going to have uh
let's go like this, right? And we'll make it a little bit bigger.
All right. So,
we'll go like this.
And then we'll go like this.
>> Oh god. Assold [clears throat] paint segment. Let's
go. >> Okay. Um,
and so the graph here is called quality of life. Okay. And here's
what happens is that you start with a with a Democrat and things
get worse. And so you hope that you can vote for a Republican
and then things will get better. But guys, both parties, everybody's
just getting the bag. It's all They're just It's a puppet show.
It's kayfabe. It's all fake. Guys, both parties are just making
sure billionaires can cash out.
Well, while in my heart of hearts, I do sort of believe this
is the effect that, you know, an incredibly partisan Congress
has or incredibly partisan government. It's just so it's so lazy.
If this is just your your lens for
you guys are getting screwed. you guys
>> but then they don't so they get worse and then you think
>> hopefully hopefully there's something beyond this. >> Okay,
well we're gonna vote for a Democrat because the Republican didn't
make things better and then they get worse and then you think
well this Democrat didn't do anything. All right, well we're
going to vote for a Republican this time. Then things will get
better but then they get worse and then so now you have a Republican.
So you think to yourself, okay, well you know what we need to
do? we need to get a real Democrat in here like we used to have
all the way back up here and then if we do that now things will
get better and so they vote for a Democrat and then things get
worse and so then after that they think all right well listen
we've had Dem and then eventually they're like wait these two
parties are screwing us let's vote for a third party and then
your country's economy collapsed okay you you destroyed the world
economy everybody's cost of living became totally untenable and
that billionaire who was voted in made off with like billions
of dollars, like tripled his net worth. Isn't that better when
you guys skipped out of the two-party system? If anything, you'd
have to agree that the argument here is that Trump is the made
guy. Trump is the fake candidate to show that a third party can
never win. Like, he's the best you'll ever get and he just screwed
you guys. Look how hard this is. He just you guys over. The best
argument you can make on this front for Trump is that he everybody
way harder than anyone else and that he was like a lesson from
from like the global cabal that controls the world. Never try
to get Never try to escape. Okay. Never try to escape. You're
here forever. >> Democrats a long time. But does anybody
remember the good old days of Reagan or George Bush? Well, you
know what we need to do? We need to vote for a Republican.
>> So then they listen for two more seconds. I do one of
them improve the quality of life. And they all are basically
surviving on pingponging nostalgia from the previous president
that they mistakenly believe was actually trying to help them.
But at the time, the previous president made it worse themselves.
So that's it. Okay, that's what's happened. >> And the
results are always the same. >> No matter which way the
political pendulum swings, Republican or Democrat, nothing ever
gets better for the common American man or woman. >> No,
they don't. >> The debt goes higher. Corporate and global
interest. >> Oh, and by the way, every graph supports what
I'm saying. All the graphs agree with me.
>> Remain Washington sweethearts. American jobs continue
to be replaced whether it's by illegal labor or legal labor.
>> So I I need somebody to come up with a solution that
is the actual solution or I I don't know what I need cuz maybe
you just get jailed if you come up with the actual solution.
How are you going to fix this? What are you going to do? Say
what fixes it. Say the thing you want to do to fix it. Don't
just identify the problem. Identify the solution you believe
in. This is what got Andrew Yang. People mock Andrew Yang all
the time. Andrew Yang at least had some plan. Andrew Yang went,
"Hey, here are the problems. Here's my solution." You can hate
the solution. You can say he's a goober, a loser, a nerd, whatever.
But at least he tried to come and say, "There needs to be a paradigm
shift or everybody's going to get,
right?" I understand a whole bunch of people I actually don't
know why people hate Andrew Yang that much to be honest with
you. It seems like he was saying a lot of things that really
needed to be said and just everybody hated him. It doesn't It
actually doesn't make sense to me. Like when I ask about this,
people never have a good reason for why they dislike him other
than basically thinking that the that the actual Yang Gang was
like off-putting,
which I agree with, right? Like I think I think the Yang Gang
was offputting, but is that enough of a reason to go, "Yeah,
this guy forever." I just don't think so.
I don't know. >> Or buy visas or just shipped overseas.
>> Yep, she's right. >> Small business. >> Not
even that I think his solution was the best solution. I'm not
even arguing that. All I would argue is I just don't understand
why the only guy who is like, "Hey, the current paradigm is going
to end with everybody getting totally destroyed." Why did that
guy get like totally written off? UBI doesn't work. Well, his
So, his examples of the problem were um actually automation is
going to start making it so jobs can't stay here. We're going
to continue to have the economy progress in this exact way and
people are going to be totally economically
like
there will just we'll just have major collapses in this country.
That's what he was saying. like the whole time and he was like
I think UBI is the way to solve that and I don't understand why
when it was clear he was totally correct in identifying the problem
he's the only one who was identifying the problem at that time
right I don't understand why he was totally written off
he had done worse than Bernie I just think like he did a very
good job at actually identifying the issues and everything he
wrote about everything he talked about is still like I would
say the only thing I feel like he got wrong is that he thought
the first industry that was going to affected was trucking. That
was wrong. AI went in a different direction, right? AI is now
targeting basically getting rid of optimizing out white collar
jobs. But he was totally correct in like the progression of how
it would be that slowly we'd need fewer and fewer humans to do
the same work and we can't fill the economic gap. There's no
lump of labor here. The labor is not required. The labor cannot
be effectively utilized cannot be effectively utilized elsewhere.
Anywhere where all of these surplus,
anywhere where people could go in a pinch to get jobs, those
are being filled by people who are there just aren't enough jobs.
Okay,
there's a lot of different causes. I don't want to I don't want
to blame immigrants cuz I think it's probably the lowest the
lowest. That was I think Andrew Yang's point is immigration is
actually the lowest
although it is a factor, it is probably the lowest grade, the
lowest wor the least worrying factor in jobs disappearing. He
was too soon. He was too soon. continue to be swallowed by big
corporations. Americans hard-earned tax dollars always fund foreign
wars, foreign aid, and foreign interest, and the spending power
of the dollar continues to decline. >> That's right. >> The
average American family can no longer survive on a single bread
winner's income. >> Well, this has been the case for 40
>> as both parents have to work in order to simply survive.
Exactly. And today, many in my children's generation feel hopeless
for their future and don't think they will ever realize.
>> Okay, so it's just that he was a goober. That feels
really unsatisfying to me cuz like a lot of people I feel like
people try to come up with intellectual reasons they oppose Yang
and then when you ask them about it, they just basically say,
"Oh no, he um he's like a goober." It's it's crazy. The one guy
who identified the solution was a goober. It's like it's like
every climate change disaster, every apocalypse movie that ever
existed where the scientist comes in and is like, "This is going
to happen. We're in big trouble." And the president of the United
States is like, "No, you're not. America's the you're wrong."
No, we're not. America's the greatest country on Earth. We're
going to get through this with no problems. And then the asteroid
hits Earth. Okay.
It's
Oh, whoops. That's Andrew Yang. He's the scientist. Okay. He's
explaining, "Guys, I think the I think there's aliens coming."
and the aliens blow up the white house
the American dream >> just because they won't cuz you got
to be asleep that's the reason why there are some people that
will be successful
but the reality is that that number is getting smaller and the
barrier to entry for a life of dignity is becoming higher every
single year
this is true
absolutely true
is like undeniably true that's a even a good way to describe
I think denying that if you're somebody who watches Asthma Gold
I like I do and you deny that part that the barrier to entry
if you want to describe it that is much more difficult than it
ever has been to just live a life of dignity where you are happy
you're not in debt you're not concerned about your finances all
the time that has never been higher there's never been more effort
required to live that life your labor is worth less and less
and less every year and that's a concerning trend okay for anybody
who's not you know super special starting a new company that
changes the whole world. And eventually as your labor becomes
less valuable, you'll stop being able to save capital to start
your own ventures. Like the the barrier to entry there as you
as you don't have like these things you can do, these innovations
you can make, you you'll have to be even more special to ever
live to ever escape your class. We're and that realistically
class mobility is the thing that makes America special,
right? If you can't escape your class, if you're stuck somewhere
forever, you've taken away what makes America special. America's
always been the country where you can go in, you can come up
with an idea and you can become a millionaire. You can become
like bonkers wealthy.
But as the as your labor becomes less valuable, as you lose the
ability to like actually save money and make meaningful contributions
as one person,
that that goes away too.
And that would be the the death of America. You you lose your
class mobility in America. That would be the absolute death.
Okay? It will become harder and harder to live a life of dignity.
It's harder now than it was 10 years ago. It was harder 10 years
ago than it was 20 years ago. And 10 years from now, it will
be even harder than it is today.
>> And that breaks my heart. >> That's the way it
is. >> I ran for Congress in 2020 and have fought every
single day believing that make America great again meant America
first. I have one of the most concerned. >> Why would you
think that if Trump has never said anything negative about Israel?
And if you can think of one negative thing that Trump said about
Israel, you can find 50 other positive things that he said about
it. Trump has said even before he was president that he would
push on on having a war with Iran. He said he was going to end
wars already. Like I feel like with that he's definitely delivered
on it. Now you can make the argument that like he didn't say
these certain things about China, etc. But I would say that in
a lot of cases he's actually been relatively uh like I I >> wait
one to are you saying welfare queens are empirically proven?
Is that that's empirically proven welfare queening is a thing?
>> I think he's been relatively globalist. I mean not entirely
and much less than like somebody like Obama for example. But
he's been relatively globalist for a very long time.
>> Voting records in Congress defending
>> bro. You can just tell I I know everything when I watch
Asmin Gold, everything about him is just um he's like a big Fentes
fan. He's he everything Nick says he believes like one to one.
H it's it's crazy. I think
I regret being in a a space where I had like the exact right
read on the Fentes thing all along and
I was like literally just maligned for it constantly. I regret
like not writing that stuff down, like ringing the the bell on
that a lot more. Man, I feel like I had the exact correct read
on how that was going to go. And I I can't even like I can't
even profit off of the correct read cuz I didn't I was like,
"Oh, I can't talk about this publicly cuz this community will
like start spreading rumors about me, start lying about me."
>> The first amendment, second amendment, unborn babies
because I believe God creates life at conception and I love to
fight for the little guy. Strong, safe borders. I have fought
hard for that. I fought against COVID tyrannical insanity and
mandated mass
>> I can't do the whole thing again. I just was going to
see if we had any any cool [__] here. >> I
was wondering what he was going to say about like what she's
going to do after >> and tried to destroy me. >> I
wanted a racist. >> It was all so absurd and completely
unserious.
I refuse to be a battered wife, hoping it all goes away and gets
>> Uhhuh. If I am cast aside by the president and the MAGA
political machine and replaced by neocons's big pharma big tech
military >> Republicans are still lesser of two evils at
this point. I I generally agree with you. I would never vote
for a Democrat because they want to introduce the reason why
I would never vote for a Democrat is because Democratic policy
enables people that would put me at a disadvantage because of
my race or my
Like just period like that to me like that. I am a single issue
voter with
>> Oh, I now want to see did Asmin Gold watch the Mandani
thing.
Oh man, I wish there was a segment on that. Just Asmin Gold reacting
to that Mandani policy cuz I feel like that is how so many so
many people would view this is they'd view it as like that's
it's actually just totally that he would write that. I think
he gets super upset. If you put me at a disadvantage because
of my race or my gender, I will never vote for you under any
circumstances. Period.
That's progress.
That's
You can't get mad about that, right? I don't think you can get
mad about that at all.
That that's that exact position. You could say Asmin Gold's not
leaning into that exact position or he's not like being honest
about it, but that position is basically everybody's got that
position. You've ever wondered why why certain races vote against
Republicans almost uni uniformly as a block of voters? It's basically
that >> progressives. Yeah, but the Democrats empower the
progressives. That's the problem. And you should never do that,
by the way. Like everybody else should feel the same way. Like
if you're a black guy, Indian guy, Asian guy, you should do the
same thing I'm doing. industrial war complex, foreign leaders,
and the elite donor class that can never ever relate to real
Americans than many
>> How does that position affect him? Uh, he would say
like things like DEI, anything that that discriminates against
whites,
right? Zoron's policy, his his whole thing in the in the platform
that the part where it like names the race that they're going
to be taxing more, that would upset him. I'm almost positive.
I don't think he'd quite go to the pobic level of like refusing
to listen at all, but just the fact that you include the white
part in there is very offputting to a lot of people. >> Americans
have been cast aside and replaced as well. There is no plan to
save the world or a 4D chess game being played. when common
people realize and understand that the political industrial complex
of both parties is ripping this country apart that not one elected
leader like me is able to stop
does she not understand why military-industrial complex was like
different saying the military-industrial complex runs politics
why that's a different thing
like listen the industrial politics of a specific thing runs
the specific thing. You wouldn't say the football industrial
complex runs the NFL and think you're making an intelligent statement.
She's talking about the political industrial complex
that's in Washington. Yes, there is politics and there's a lot
of business intertwined. Yes,
you're like trying to work in military-industrial complex for
no reason. >> This machine from gradually destroying our
country and instead the reality is that they common Americans,
the people possess the real power over Washington.
>> then I'll be here >> not for much longer. Every
single day that things continue in the current status quo, your
power becomes less. You are losing everything. Everything is
I I feel like in a real sense,
I don't know
what I would advise people to do. I feel like in my head
probably anybody who's going to tell you the truth, anybody who's
saying they're going to do something that's a paradigm shift,
they're probably lying. I don't think anybody's really willing
to grapple with what you'd have to do to like make it so American
quality of life could start going back up again. Cuz let me tell
you, in terms of your your labor being devalued, you're not even
close to rock bottom yet, right? Like it's not even you're not
even in the same
stratosphere as where your labor should
Like your labor is going to continue to be devalued over and
over and over again for like every year
for the next 20 years. Like I don't I don't actually know how
far the world's going to go at this point. But I'm not trying
to demoralize. I'm saying that nobody's actually telling the
truth about the problems. Puggyups. I'm not saying there's no
way to fix it either. There isn't no way to fix it. There are
some ways to fix it. But like a lot of stuff has to change
and I think the people who would advocate for that change
probably wouldn't be platformed for very long. You'd probably
have to break to say what the changes would have to be. Like
I think I think it would require like a revolution basically
some kind of revolution. I'm not saying like a socialist revolution,
some kind of revolution. Things would have to change very very
very significantly and it would be like years and years of hardship
and you're not even remotely at the level of hardship required
to go for
But what you guys are going to do is probably I would imagine
have a standard of living for long enough where you know these
tech oligarchs are going to figure out how to do drone swarms.
You know Palmer Lucky is going to figure out how to protect all
the billionaires and you'll no shot probably something like that,
right? They'll just it'll be like a
it'll be like neo
neocurfdom what what do you call that? Oh feudalism neutralism,
right? I think that's probably where you're headed. by their
side to rebuild it. Until then, I'm going back to the people
that I love to the to live my life.
>> Yeah, Peter Teal, Peter Teal, network state guys. Those
are guys those guys are going to win >> to the fullest
as I always have and I look forward to a new path ahead. >> I'll
be resigning from office with my last day being January 5th,
2026.
>> And I look forward to seeing many of you again sometime
in the future. May God bless you all and may God bless America.
>> I am very torn on whether this is the like the right
way of doing things or not. Like I I'm I'm I'm very divided on
it. And I don't know if you guys feel the same way on it where
it's like there's a part where it's like okay well if you think
that it's this bad then stand and fight, right? Give up. But
at the same time, you know, you've invested so much of yourself
into this movement and the move the movement leader has effectively
repudiated you and said that you are
I don't believe this at all. Anybody who's reading this into
a Marjorie Marjgery Taylor Green is a psychotic silverback gorilla.
She doesn't know how to go, oh, it wouldn't really be that effective
a use of my time to back down right or to fight with Trump right
now. She's a psychotic silverback gorilla. She just doesn't believe
that. She thinks that in the very near future she will be able
to attack Donald Trump. She'll be on the winning side by doing
this. I do not believe for a second that she's actually just
saying, "Okay, I'm going to actually I'm going to go in like
I'm just going to go live my life out here in Georgia." Nope.
Not happening. Are an enemy and that they're going to try to
disadvantage you and attack you at every point. Like at that
point,
yeah, but but the people who are going to do this, this is going
to to do this Porterbellar, you'd have to consolidate power in
a way that if America does, you're just going to end up with
an authoritarian running it, right?
Same thing with every socialist revol every kind of revolution.
Basically, it just ends with this. There's like
it's I don't know if you if you want this if this is what you
think needs to happen you probably need to go engage with Curtis
Jarvin stuff and go oh maybe he has some points I think
there's like no good out at this point >> and also like
she's probably not going to win again like realistically and
I I that's that's the problem right and so why even play a game
that you know you're going to lose
Bernie Sanders it did yeah but that yeah but what happened with
him he lost >> he's going to try to step out and maintain
relevance let JD have a I if he fails, she can come in as the
purest. She will fail. Um maybe maybe her ego is big enough that
she thinks she's got people who care about her beyond like her
being the the house member who will say base things. But I think
that is pure ego and she's going to find out what she's actually
worth to people really quickly if that's her plan. >> So
yeah, that nobody votes. So the one with the money wins. Uh term
limits are the solution. We want you new young people in the
government. That's how we get it. Term limits don't allow young
people in the government. they just allow new people in the government.
Like I don't understand why you expect that that's going to change.
So I I don't know really what you would why you would say that,
but like you know that's just how that that's how I see it at
least, right? If she gets her appointments removed, she effectively
she is effectively lame duck. Well, I don't know about that.
I'm telling you she's my district rep. I I promise you that she
would win again. Maybe, maybe not, right? I don't know yet. But
uh you don't even know who's running against her, but uh so it's
hard really to say. Either way, um I am extremely torn on this.
I I I don't really know whether I agree with her or not about
this. I think that the thing is that she's said some crazy stuff
in the past and I think that she's been very um performative
in the past in the way that she's behaved. But in general um
the things that she said in this video, I didn't disagree with
a single one of them except for like maybe a minor thing about
the H-1B visa thing. Like overall I agreed with everything that
she said. I I I did. And I feel like again like basically
>> now this is something that will actually start to tip
things in my mind. Okay, I think she's like a total [__]
loser. I think she's like totally out to lunch.
But there is an element of if she puts some things out into the
zeitgeist and this the right people support her, she could catch
on in some ways. Uh I tend to think Asold just hasn't watched
the Fuentes segment on this to know the opinion that he should
have, right? The opinion he actually wants to have. I'm guessing
there'll be some nuance shifting towards whatever Fuentes's opinion
is from him. We'll see. Lasers. >> I didn't agree with
the space lasers. I I don't think that there are I think that
there are space lasers, but I don't think that they're necessarily
>> Oh, anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go,
guys. We have an hour 33 left on the stream. Can if you guys
like the content, I need you to dig deep in your hearts and your
wallets. Donate a couple bucks to the stream, okay? add more
time. Let's get more time on the stream. We still got a whole
bunch of other stuff to do for tonight. Okay, there's a bunch.
We could check out some of Fentes's coverage. Might might do
that. I don't think he reads the or I don't think he watches
the video. So, I scanned it really quickly just to see if he
was going to watch the same video so I wouldn't watch it like
multiple times. I don't think he watches the video. Okay, so
we check that out.
Uh guys, so donate add more time basically. Subs, kick subs,
um Streamlabs donation link, kickbot donation link. Okay. Any
way you can. There's also the Patreon. Appreciate all the support.
You guys do support a lot. Okay. There's the links. You can donate.
Add more time to the stream. Appreciate every dollar donated.
Love you guys. Don't forget to buy kicks as well. Go ahead, buy
some kicks. Throw them in the pot. All right. Throw pennies.
Why aren't you guys throwing pennies anymore? Used to throw pennies
as like an an anti-semitic canard calling me and then you don't
throw pennies anymore. It's [__] up.
All right, let's continue.
I think that there are other people besides the that control
the space lasers also.
Okay. Like that's it was proven to be real. Yeah, of course.
Right. But it's about the it's about the space. We know that
they're space lasers, but are they space lasers? That's the question,
right? And so anyway, uh that's that's not what she said. Media
made it up. Well, either I don't I don't know. I don't care.
It doesn't matter. It's funny to talk about, but it doesn't really
make a difference. So, yes. Anyway, uh I didn't see that coming.
Is she quitting uh to join some news or for big bucks? I think
that's the way a lot of people feel about it. Uh she left because
she realizes the government is rotted. Is this real? She's checking
out. Didn't see that coming. And uh this is honestly a shocker.
Yeah, I mean I guess so. Is this her? Yeah, I guess that's her.
>> What's she saying? Uh
this is about it. Yeah. 21,000
uh replies. Oh my god. This was very controversial [snorts] and
I would never imagine saying this, but don't go stay and fight.
I mean, I think that
>> Dude, I think I think this isn't so to
Thank you for leaving. Enjoy selling out to the radical left.
Maybe there is a threat you're not mentioning. If so, understood.
If you're truly dropping out due to the nastiness, you should
reconsider. Use your power in a split house to drive your agenda
and then don't run for re-election. If you're truly done rather
than quit early. Yeah, basically there's just no reason to respect
this if she's just running away. >> Probably taking a break.
Thank you for
>> Good riddance. Good luck on Rob. enjoy selling out to
the radical left. >> Jesus Christ. I do think that she
is making such a huge mistake by trying to look for the approval
on mainstream media and by traditional celebrities.
You have burned the boats and you don't realize it yet. And this
is maybe good. If she's going for the influencer thing, if that's
like her angle, she wants to be just an influencer like Matt
Gates or whoever the [__] else from the Freedom Caucus.
Okay. I think she doesn't understand her biggest problem is that
she doesn't feel like she's treated with any dignity, right?
She wants bigger roles. She wants to be more respected. If she
go decides to go to the media, if she decides to be a influencer
in any
>> hold on.
>> Full of hell with gifted sub. Thank you very much. If
she decides to be an influencer, the thing that's going to work
against her is nobody who platforms her will respect her. They
won't have respect for her, right? She'll be like uh she's going
to have to be a different she's going to have to be a silverback
gorilla for somebody else. And that's just that's rough. Okay.
She's looking for respect. The only way she gets respect is by
going to Congress and giving like meaningful passionate actual
speeches like actual speeches, actual defenses of positions,
get like passing effective legislation.
This is her only route to being like effective or or good
and respected is by actually being a politician, buckling down.
She didn't do that for the past 8 years. just not what she's
been doing, right?
So, I don't know why she's she's kidding herself if she thinks
she can go the influencer route and get any respect or have any
reach. Crowder is so damn bad he would have her join his show.
I don't know if Crowder's down bad. I don't know what his viewership's
like.
reminder of who MTG is. >> I'm told my predecessor called
members of Congress in the Senate to demand they block the bill.
>> He feels the political win he'll be a political win
for me and a political loser for him. It's not
Watch Kamla. Watch Kamla.
The little the little micro reaction when he slurs >> He
viewed it as if it'll be a political win for me and a political
loser for >> It's not
>> just a little twitch in the mouth. Okay. Joe, keep it
together, Joe. Joe, keep it together, Joe. >> It's not
about me.
>> I'd be a winner.
Not really. >> I
[laughter]
I'd be a winner.
Not really. >> I Lincoln
Lincoln Riley, an innocent young woman who was killed >> by
an illegal.
That's right. But how many of thousands of people being killed
by illegals
to her?
Wait, what? God, Joe is so broken at this point. Actually, yeah,
the violent illegals coming to the country are thousands of people.
You're you're right. He doesn't EVEN KNOW WHAT HIS POSITIONS
ARE. DUDE, how did you guys How did people think this guy could
run? Was this after he dropped out? March. When did he drop out?
It wouldn't have been Would it have been March?
No, it wasn't. Right. I think he was still It was pretty close
to this. When was the first debate? First
Otus debate 2024.
When was this? June 27th. It was 3 months after this. Dude, he
was in a rough spot. Holy.
Yeah, it was it was June or sorry, it the first it was the first
debate he did it in, right? It was where his brain
June 27th, 2024.
Oh, he dropped out in July. Okay. Okay. I was just talking about
his like final bro. He was rough. He was rough. He was in a rough
spot. Okay.
That is who MTG is. She fought with them. She's the person who
fights over all the the stupid populist wedge issues. God, have
they found a new By the way, have they found a new corpse yet?
Or are they just going to keep I guess Charlie Kirk is the new
corpse that they're using?
The Lake and Riley stuff. Thank god that ended, dude. Thank [__]
God. They they took that dead girl and they rode her. They surfed
her on a wave for like two years. That was their number one.
Okay,
now they've got St. Charlie that they can run on. Thank god.
Like Riley can finally be put to rest. Finally.
All right. Where are we going next? I think I was done with this.
We could watch a little bit of that Fuentes segment. What else
do I got here? I'll probably do the Shay segment no matter what.
So, huh. Before we get off of Asmin Gold, I'm just going to watch
the Asmin Gold thing really quickly. The other Asmin Gold thing
I had. We could do maybe we do Fentes in the Patreon or something
after this if if we go there. Okay. All right. But let's look
at this.
what is this? Asmagold says, "Deport the Fox News reporter who
tried a gotcha question at the Trump Mumdani meeting to Karen
Island."
To Karen meeting to Karen Island. Deport her to Karen Island.
Okay. The Karen right here is the reason why everything is bad.
Media doesn't actually want to make anything better. They just
want division. Is this the fascist question?
We need to get this dumb out of the press. Really? Like this
this stupid
this Karen right here is the reason why everything is bad. Do
you remember what I said about how all problems in the world
come from two groups of people? Karens and incelss. That's one
of them right there. She's Fox News. Deport
deport her. Okay. Like I don't know if I don't know if getting
her out of the press is enough. I think we might have to have
a deportion.
That's how it should be. Maybe that's piggy. A deportion.
We should have a deportion,
guys.
We're not going to we're not going to have a deportation of a
deportion.
>> Sorry. I shouldn't be I shouldn't be nitpicky on pronunciation,
especially given my misbeh.
Definitely should be. Silence, piggy. Yep, there it is. Where
are the media incelss, though? Well, I don't know about that.
And uh yeah, send her to Alligator Alcatraz. Deport her to Canada.
Yeah, we need to have like a Karen Island, you know, like maybe
it's like send them over to Cuba, something like that. Annoying.
Absolutely. What a stupid, man. And uh I Jesus,
I don't know. By the way,
I say this, okay? I've said this for a long time, but you know,
that's that's another Fentesism. Okay, this stupid. When I do
that voice, that's me doing the Fentesto voice when he calls
somebody a [__] This
That's how he says it. I I feel like Asmin Gold's been watching
a lot >> I just We We really got to I I think we got to
call this out more. the fact that the media doesn't actually
want to make anything better.
The the real enemy aren't the Democrats or the Republicans, depending
on which side you're on. It's the media >> because the
media wants division. They want hostility. They want arguments
because they want money. That's all they are. That's all they'll
ever be. >> So, yeah, it's that simple. I think they're
a necessary evil personality. No, there's too many Karens. Maybe
a few Karens could be a necessary evil, but we have way too many
of them. They're way overpowered. There's too many of them. We
have to have a uh you know a redu
Okay.
Okay. All right.
Very I guess interesting opinion. The thing that made this interesting
was the pop of gut response. Okay.
The pop gut response. It's funny how Trump in every other scenario
invites conservative media to harass people he doesn't like.
We saw that with Zilinsky, but since Trump didn't respond positively
to it this time, Asminold magically finds it a problem. It's
almost as if his talking points are Trump good. Unless it's indefensible,
then it's just a downplay of bad behavior or a lie by omission.
Uh, I don't even think that's necessarily wrong. I think that's
actually kind of accurate for Papa Gut. Maybe the most accurate
Papa Gut's ever been. Now, I will say Asmin Gold saw this, did
not like this tweet. Okay, Asminold was not a fan. Asminold responded.
Let's check this out really quickly. Okay, every good idea and
they're going to have every good viewpoint and they're going
to see eye to eye with you on everything, right? It's just not
how it how it works. And the port was favor scenario invites
conservative media harass doesn't like uh since Trump didn't
respond positively as my fun is a problem. His talking points
are Trump good unless it's indefensible. Nope. Uh this is it.
We got a we got a bald bald. We got a bald or it's too bad. It's
too bad because asminold also listen best papa gut take followed
by best asminold take. Who wins? I don't know who wins. I'm very
Any of those media people that were in the the White House yesterday
trying to egg on hostility between Trump and Mandami are enemies
of America.
They are in the name is right there. There's not an M there.
There's not an M. It's written right there.
It's written right there. Enemies of He's doing it intentionally.
I don't know why this is like to me
this is like one of the higher levels maybe the highest level
of disrespect that you can do in like a passive way to do this
to people. I go out of my way to figure out how not to do this
to people because I think I think it actually goes some distance
is you just learn how to say people's names even people you don't
like because it shows that you take them seriously. You're like
something there. And then there are the people who intentionally
mispronounce other people's names all the time. And I it just
it makes no sense.
Right. It makes no [__] sense. Oh, this is a good
question. Yeah. Would that would that apply to Jack Pobic?
Jack Pobic really wanted them to fight. Jack Pobic was like,
"She's taxing whites. Trump, Trump, you're the great white savior
and he's taxing white people." More Trump,
please.
He an enemy of America. >> To egg hostility between Trump
and Mandami are enemies of America. They are enemies of the people.
They are enemies of peace. They are enemies of progress. And
they will actively work to make your life worse so they can report
on it and make more money. They are literal parasites. They
now while I don't necessarily think this is entirely wrong,
my question would be
that's different from what you do. How how is that? Wait, how
is that how is that any different from Asminold covering video
game news ever? Is there any difference at all? Has Asminold
ever covered like some video game dev?
I swear to God, all the anti-woke stuff, it's like he just wants
to make their lives worse to profit from it. Yeah. No, I think
so. Feed. And the answer here, of course, is well, no. They they
think there's like a principle they're standing up for. They
they feel like Trump is in violation of some principle. So they
try to maintain that and they try to ask questions based on you
know hey this is bad this is a bad thing you're doing just like
you do as gold when you're like yeah you put another black person
in this game I don't like that a black samurai really when you
think you have to like destroy people's lives because they put
a black samurai in Assassin's Creed that's exactly you're operating
from the same perspective oh they've done something very bad
it's damaging to the fabric of society and I need to make this
stop and I can make this stop and I'm in a position where I need
to call it out that's congratulations you're just like them on
strife, discourse, discord, and hostility.
That is what they want. It's not unique to her. She was a stupid
[__]
But there are plenty of other stupid [__] in that
room, too.
>> She just happened to ask the most
>> Stupid theory. >> And he had to survive. Yes,
exactly. They're absolute parasites.
Anybody and I I would say this. Anybody who saw the Trump Mandami
meeting and is trying to be like, "Oh, Mandami won. Trump won.
You know who actually won is the American people because you
had two groups of people that completely disagreed with each
other that were willing to put aside their differences to work
towards some Uh-huh.
DUDE.
Or you just had a mayor who doesn't want his city invaded and
doesn't want Donald Trump to pull all funding from it and so
he kissed the ring because that's what you do. So you don't over
the people behind you who who backed you.
Dude, these people just wanted to work together. One of them
was threatening to kill the other one. Like literally just ruin
the other person's life, ruin their city, ruin everything, right?
Like that's Are you sure that that's what was happening? Or does
Trump just have all the leverage in the world and people have
to pretend that he's not a loser? Something that would benefit
American citizens.
So no, Asmin Gold's been somewhat defensive of Mani. I don't
think Asmin Gold hated Mani. I don't think he thinks Asminold
is a third positionist. Unironically, you guys maybe don't understand
that he is a third positionist. Asminold is one of those guys
who is like, I'm not a Republican. I'm like I like both sides.
No, he is a third positionist. Absolutely. Wants so more socially
conservative. Wants culture to stop moving as fast. And he is
okay with a lot of social programs. He's okay with a ton of stuff.
A ton of healthare, ton of things like this. Now, he'll cut other
stuff on populist grounds. Should he be paying for illegal immigrants
in some way? No. But for people in his country who look like
him, okay? He's like basically Marx.
He's more or less Marx. He's just an unironic third positionist.
Don't get it confused. Don't get it twisted. If you ever think
he's like libertarian or something, that's not true.
That's why he likes Mani. That's why he was okay with Mum Donnie
in some ways. I don't think I actually don't even think the race
thing's that big a deal for Asminold to be honest with you. Like
I think I don't think he dislikes people on the basis of race.
I think he is willing to argue for himself on the basis of race
because he wants he doesn't want to feel like white people can't
do that. But I don't think he's like overtly racist to other
groups to be honest with you. >> Oh, any of those people
are enemies of America. They don't want your life to get worse
or sorry, they don't want your life to get better. They want
it to get worse. They want it to get worse so they can keep blaming
the person that they've been blaming for the last 5 years.
That's it. Damn. No, I'm serious. I hate him. I hate him. I hate
I hate them. I don't like them.
>> Oh, God forbid people with opposing views can agree
on things. I'm so tired, man. The reason why it's like that is
because we have been captured by the lowest common denominator
of voter. That's it. So, has he at all engaged with what's being
said by Papa Gut? Papa Gut said asminold actually supports people
asking these questions that are like intentionally
uh causing friction that are trying to put two people against
each other. That's the criticism. Asmin Gold supports those questions.
All you're saying is I hate the people who do this, who do like
this thing, who ask these questions, try to cause discord between
two people who are trying to come together.
It's like, no, you don't. You've literally been behind other
people doing this.
I bet you I Dude, we maybe we could watch his coverage. I wonder
what he says when Pobic asks because I guarantee you he's behind
it there, right? Well, I should say I shouldn't say I guarantee
you. Hold on. youtube.com/asminoldtv.
Oh, hold on. Asminold. Oh, what the is Asmin Gold's channel on
YouTube? Why won't this load? I want Asmin Gold's Mandani reaction.
Let's take a look. Let's give it a quick look. This is the White
House. I >> want to congratulate I think you're going to
>> So, we'll look for white white
>> campaign was minority
to do. He's right. bills, etc. And >> you know, I he actually
uh people would be shocked, >> but I want to see the same.
>> I by the way, I've not seen it. I don't know what's
going to be said. I feel like he will criticize Pobic for doing
this. Okay. I think I think he'll be consistent here, but I don't
even have to do any more work if he's not consistent here because
Papa's just proven correct. So, we'll see. He He can't He has
to be careful because I know for a fact he's going to have the
position where he wants to criticize Madani. He wants to say
that's a good question. Right. But it is actually just causing
strife between them. It is just to try to get them to fight.
So Jack Pobic doing the exact same thing that he chastised that
Karen for. >> Same thing. >> Mr. Anti-Israel protesters.
>> Jack, Mr. President, I wanted to know one of the uh
policies as well that uh Mayor Le Madami talked a number of times
about on the campaign was shifting the tax burden for property
taxes from what he called minority communities to whitebased
communities. Oh yeah, taxes on white people. I also noticed that
in your acceptance speech you didn't mention uh didn't mention
anything about America in general and so I didn't know if that
was some one of the policies that you guys >> Oh god I
just realized Jack Bobic's like echoing Sneo right here. You
didn't even mention white people in your acceptance
>> Talking about we focused on affordability. We focused
on the cost of living crisis. What I will say is that I am very
much interested in property tax reform because what we see right
now in New York City is a system that is so inequitable that
it can't even stand up in court. And the president and I spoke
about the importance of not only building more housing, but also
making sure that regulation of housing is something that is manageable
to get through and not the cause of yet another weight that we
see. >> But to be clear, you're continuing this idea of
race-based property taxes. >> No, to be very clear what
you said. No, the the the use of the term was a description of
neighborhoods, not a description of intent. >> So, you
intend to tax the whiter >> Dude, this is great. He's like,
it's not a description of intent. So, you intend to tax the white
people more.
How is Jack Pobic this dumb? Like, even if I agreed with him
completely, which I maybe agree Mani should walk back the language
a little bit. Jack Pobic is the worst person who could have pressed
him on this. That's what he just said. He didn't do >> tax
system because we want a New York City that is not only fair
and equitable but also one that every New York can
>> I mean, he shouldn't have said that, but still. [laughter]
>> Go ahead. >> Mr. Maldani, anti-Israel protesters.
>> He just said no. >> A synagogue in New York. Are
you concerned about New Yorkers feeling welcome and safe in the
city? And >> hold on. He did push back on Jack. Hold on.
Not in the same way. Not in the same way. He just goes, "Oh,
don't. Why did you ask him?" He just said that. He's just calling
Jack dumb. He's not saying anybody who asks He's not doing the
same thing where it's anybody who asks this question. Anybody
who tries to get these two to fight on something, they're a piece
of [__] Also, why is Scott Besson just lurking about
to knock somebody out? Just lurking in the corner.
This guy, this guy's knocked out multiple people in the White
House already. He's just looking for his next victim. Okay, who
the can he punch next?
Maybe it's going to be Jack Bobic.
>> President Trump, you've threatened to cut off federal
funding to New York City. What policies would prompt you to do
that? Would that be city-run grocery stores? Would it
>> He's actually dismissed the Secret Service. It's only
only Scott Besset needs to be here now. Okay. Secret Service,
you guys can walk off. Let somebody try something. Let I wish
a would. Okay. Secret Service doesn't need to be here. I'm all
the protection the president needs. >> Something else.
Well, I think if we didn't get along, whether it's cut off or
just make it a little bit difficult or not give as much, we want
to see, I use the term, we don't want good money going after
bad. And uh we just uh we don't want that to happen. I don't
think that's going to happen. I did say that, you know, subject
to >> what is this compar what is the comparison? The question
he wanted her deported for was the most innane question. This
is a policy question.
>> Wait, you think you think talking about authenticity
is an inane question? Hey, you guys have like gone like gang
busters on each other, calling each other fascist, communist.
Doesn't that seem a little weird now that you're all jolly here?
Seems like you're almost inauthentic. You don't think that's
a legitimate question? Why should I believe anything these two
say if they're going to say anything they can to get elected?
I thought it was Maybe I missed it. Maybe I misunderstood. We
need to get this dumb out of the press. Really? Like this this
stupid
this Karen right here. Oh, hold on. Why did you fly here? Oh,
this is a different one. My bad. I didn't see the original I
didn't see the original question. I just assumed it was the fascist
question. Me? That's my bad. Why didn't you take the train today?
Okay,
that is a stupid question. I don't know. But that's
Hold on.
That doesn't even make any sense. That's like not getting them
to fight. Where's the division there? That's just like an openly
stupid question. >> We need to get this dumb out of the
press. Really? Like this this stupid
this Karen right here is the reason why everything is bad. Do
you remember what I said about how all problems in the world
come from two groups of people? Karens and incelss. That's one
of them right there. She's Fox News. Deport
deport her. Okay. Like I don't know if I don't know if
Okay.
>> I still don't I'm still not a fan. I'm still not a fan.
>> Getting her out of the press is enough. I think we might
have to have a >> She's Fox News deport.
I think we might have to have a deportion. Then he does the face.
Bro, this guy's faces are crazy. Every single time
the faces are Is it a first trimester, second trimester deportion
as gold? What trimester do you think you know the sanctity of
somebody's citizenship is there for? Okay. What trimester? Second
trimester deportions. We're we're not behind those.
Well, you see, in the first like 8 weeks, somebody can just take
a pill and they can no longer be a citizen. They're just deportioned,
okay? Immediately. And that's not really surgical. It's not really
a big deal. Sorry, I'm trying to run with the bit while I'm sick.
It's uh it's a it's a rough day, okay, to run with bits. [__]
me. And after I got in office, also an after got in office, they'll
work together. >> They better they better work together.
They better start acting like it. Yeah, that's it. Dench timu
worldview. Absolutely. It's embarrassing what these people do.
Yeah. Anybody who's trying to politicize it, anybody who's complaining
about it, anybody who's getting mad about it, these are enemies
of America.
>> Direct domestic enemies of America. Bo, you hate everyone.
I have hated a lot of >> Did he want to go off on that
guy? And he's like, I'll think about that. Okay, I'll internalize
that. >> Direct domestic enemies of America. Bo, you hate
everyone. I have hated a lot of people today. I'm gonna be honest.
Like I now now you say that
I have really been on one today, haven't
>> I've really been on one today. I've been [laughter]
I really have been. Yeah, bro. Like
>> today's been big, right? It's been a big
>> Yeah. I don't know what to say. You have a love for
hating it. People suck, though. I guess you're right. But damn.
>> Damn.
Asmin Gold getting his snark bag. Okay. This is This is the world's
most profitable snarker right here. All he does is snark all
day, every day. And he just collects the the biggest bag in the
world for it.
It's hard to tell whether or not I hate this guy for his political
positions, his video game culture positions, or if I just hate
that he makes so much money doing it. Okay. I don't know. Sometimes
he just makes so much money. I I might be blinded.
It's actually the political positions, though. For real. For
real.
Okay, I had that little I just I think I went to go find Asmin
Gold's MTG thing and then as I opened it up, I saw him like reading
a pop of gut tweet and going B alert.
Oh, by the way, I still don't think he's really addressed. Maybe
the criticism is good isn't as good. Hold on. I have to look
again now.
Where's the Where's the papa gut tweet? Let me go grab it. I
think it's bottom of the quotes here.
It's funny how Trump in every other scenario invites conservative
media to harass people he doesn't like. We saw that. Oh yeah,
hold on. No, this is still a valid criticism. Totally valid criticism,
actually.
Yeah, that's totally true. Even if it's like a stupid gotcha
question. Even it's a if it's a totally stupid gotcha question.
That's like literally the press corp Trump wants. Trump rebuilt
that press corp from the ground up, right? Isn't this the new
improved press corp that's like only only individual influencers
and like right-wing media? The one he kicked a bunch of like
normal outlets out of.
This is literally his press corps. His uniquely Trump press corps
that's asking this question.
There should be some criticism for Trump on this. No,
I think so. Oh well.
Okay, we're back to what do we got next? Gross score thing. I
got the Shay thing. Uh, that's pretty much everything. Now,
I do I did kind of want to continue to follow the Andrew Wilson
thing. Oh, is this gone? Hold on. I think I might have an archive
of this. One second.
Am I crazy? I think Riyle was archiving this. I don't know if
Ry is still awake. Oh, but hold on. I actually forgot as well.
We're going to do this and then we're on to the Shay stuff. Okay.
>> We have to watch. There's a card posting video on
card posting video on Asmin Gold. We got to watch it. Okay, title.
You can't build a civilization
out of asthma cults. You can't do it. You can't build ai a civilization,
a fully functioning civilization out of asthma golds. Can't be
done. I'm a longtime progressive community organizer and activist.
And here on my YouTube page, I like to make simple little videos
about all sorts of things which cross my mind.
Today, I just want to articulate something I've been thinking
about for some time.
Surely if you're watching this,
>> you at least vaguely know who Asmin Gold is. You know
of him.
>> World of Warcraft streamer turned wannabe loweffort
anti-woke political commentator. Incredibly dumb individual living
in a covel. That guy.
>> Okay. He's he's punching. He's punching early. Well,
there's a convincing enough argument to be made based on viewership
figures and the like to say that he is one of the singularly
most watched online figures of note these days, especially with
the young adult male
And in more recent years, in particular, he's managed to wrangle
in an increasingly large politically minded audience of self-consciously
right-wing or at least right-wingleaning people. And let's be
realistic. We mean here predominantly young white western guys.
It might be very easy for some lefties to bemoan the fact a guy
like this is evidently so influential.
After all, it means Asmin Gold himself makes a lot of money and
it means a lot of people must listen to what he has to
But I don't see the latter there especially as a big problem
myself.
And I'd like to explain why I think that
Simply put,
>> I don't necessarily think it's all that bad if the median
Twitch viewer, you know, latude.
Yeah, I sorry. I I was about to say this. Love the pie. You literally
said it as I paused to say this.
What is this guy like actually dying? His skin is like not the
same tone. It's like not even remotely uniform here. He's like
he's on a rough one right now. >> Shut type guy wastes
his own time thinking Asmin Gold is someone worth watching or
looking up to.
The thing is, Asmin Gold's lifestyle
is just not one that really anyone would benefit from living.
The home is a big pile of trash. You can't read. You just game
all day and get angry about stuff on the internet.
>> Uh, that's not true. Asmin Gold can read better than
a lot of streamers, to be honest with you. The one exception
being it just so happens that by a quirk of how society is presently
structured, Asmin Gold himself can become rich modeling these
behaviors to others. This is one of those things where it's probably
important what Asold's lifestyle is and the fact that he like
sort of allows the glorification of it is probably important,
but I would say broadly I don't think he'd if somebody ever asked
him directly, he wouldn't say, "Oh, no, my lifestyle is awesome.
you should live my lifestyle. Right now, you should be wary of
anybody who's going to live a lifestyle over and over and over
again where they don't think they're living their best life,
like they they're not even remotely attempting to. You should
probably be careful of that, right? It's like a red flag immediately.
But the longer Asmin Gold is a public figure online,
the more and more he will attract fans who will inadvertently
fall into the trap of becoming parasoccially invested in him
and becoming polarized into thinking he's right because of Multure
War.
All the while these viewers of course aren't actually building
any >> he knows he lives in a dump.
I would be very wary of anybody who is a big figure, has all
the money in the world, knows they have problems, and does nothing
to
change the problems,
right? And is like defiant about changing the problems. That's
always a massive red flag going, "Yeah, I am kind of a piece
of actually."
I'd say that's basically always a red flag, unless you're talking
about just your demeanor, but like you have a habit that like
makes you a piece of I'm sorry it that's not really a confession.
That doesn't make it okay. You the fact that you're aware of
it and not changing it doesn't make it better. >> Social
connections and they're not engaging in politics in any real
or material way,
which you might think at first is bad.
But if anything, I think it's good that his innately reactionary
viewer base is funneling themsself towards a life of inactivity
and reclusion.
>> I also don't know if there's any evidence of that. I
think I there's a lot of evidence that Asmin Gold This is I totally
disagree with this video.
Like all I need to look at is that video of the cop rolling up
to that dude. Okay, not actually too that dude, but shooting
that dude and there's Asminold playing in it. It's like, oh,
this guy gets listened to by a lot of regular people.
I don't think most of the audience is is actually modeling the
behavior.
I really don't think so. I think it's disgusting enough that
most people actually can't get there. They think they're making
a community when in reality they're just watching some guy play
games.
Asmin Gold and his other fans won't help them when they need
it. They think hearing political commentary and paring talking
points back to themselves is political action when in reality
they're not moving the needle an inch.
They consume everything secondhand
instead of even aspiring to enjoy things themselves or have their
own opinion for once and they don't even realize what they're
losing out on. I think a lot of people
is it like is it third spaces? Third it's third spaces or something,
right? What is it? It's like you have like shared social spaces
that aren't your home and aren't your job. There's like is it
third spaces? Is that the the saying?
I think it is. Right. I think that's what streams function as
is a way that you could be social with people in some way in
some minor way while you do something you'd be doing anyway.
That's maybe not the most constructive thing. You'd be like watching
videos or something, but instead of doing it by yourself, you
do it to the community because it feels like it fulfills some
human need for social contact,
right? I think that's like that is a big reason for streamers.
I think there are people who definitely watch Asmin Gold videos,
but I feel like Asmin Gold's got a pretty active fan base at
this point. Like I I would imagine Asmin Gold's engagement is
very high for the amount of people who watch him
>> and good. I'm glad the typical Asmin Gold fan is doing
that to themselves,
especially now that more and more the typical Asmin Gold fan
is likely to be some wannabe alt-right LA type. all the
that think the media is out to distract them from realizing their
racial destiny or whatever and to celebrate them. >> Oh,
I think this guy's really got Asmin Gold misread. I think there's
like some there's definitely some white identitarianism with
Asminold, but it's not at a level where he like thinks where
he would even support anybody using that kind of language. I
guarantee if somebody was like, "I'm white, but I couldn't do
this in life," Asminold would almost certainly tell them, "You
can't let yourself be discouraged." Like, that's a total loser
mentality. I don't I don't think this is a good read of Asmin
Gold's actual positions.
Um, I think Asmin Gold's like low IQ and that he thinks like
Nick Fuentes is probably not like as racist or as bad as most
people would describe him, right? But I don't I I don't think
there's like true white white identitarianism there without Asthma
Gold. Totally disagree. >> Anti-woke white guy is the biggest
Twitch streamer right now. Can't see the irony.
They're valorizing a man who is every white trash stereotype
incarnate.
And they made him famous themselves.
That's the really funny part.
The imagined elders of Zion that live only inside their own heads
could never in a million years have made such an effective agent
of demoralization.
Asminold is the perfect bread and circuses totem for millions
of little lumpen reactionary [__] cattle Americans.
By all means [laughter] keep watching white man. You like watching
one of your >> Okay. Okay. It's funny again now. Now he
used cattle in a sentence in a video. Now I'm just on card side
no matter what he says. He could tell me up is down, but he said
cattle.
Maybe you should even back. >> Or hell, you should game
all day in filth like he does yourself.
Aspire to a life with no responsibilities.
I hope you enjoy it.
the analogy to what crackco did after the CIA spread around
uh Asmigold should honestly argue against his lifestyle because
most people can't maintain that lifestyle and not be totally
demoralized and like themselves. That's like that's Asminold's
unique talent is that he can live this lifestyle and he can wake
up every day at the exact same time, do his routine, get his
stream going and manage business concerns like outside of it
too. There's he is legitimately unironically in every possible
sense built different. Okay,
most people who live that lifestyle are so depressed they can't
maintain anything consistent. Including like if you told them
to get up and watch TV at the same time every day, they couldn't
do it. They would fall out of sync with that schedule no matter
what. Asenold's totally built differently from those people.
And that's why I think he would probably argue for people not
to have his >> African-American communities under Reagan
would be a bit hackneed, but it's the same principle. You get
the idea.
See, as far as I'm concerned, the fact that so many young reactionaries
like this guy is absolutely no cause for
It's a problem that solves itself really. In 10, 15, 20 years,
they won't have grown. They won't have learned anything.
Being an Asen Gold fan is like self- selecting.
I think
what argument is he making here that doesn't apply to any major
streamer? He's basically just arguing that anybody who follows
streamer is gonna like themselves, right?
Like I think I've said this to you guys before, but if you if
you listen to the stream eight hours intentfully every day, you
shouldn't probably do that. You should probably figure something
that's probably if you are like here all the time, you're always
responding, you never have anything else going on, you pro that's
probably not good. You probably need to be putting more time
in other things. I'm just But I think most people listen in the
background a lot of the time. Most people do like a lot of other
things. Like it's not nobody's doing this full-time. They always
have it up. They always just like want to want to like respond
to everything. I know you guys can pull out the window and respond
now. I'm just telling you, you're probably not living your best
life in some ways.
Okay, just letting you know >> to waste your own time admiring
a lifestyle that is poisonous to your own interests. And it's
good that it sucks in right-wing young men that might otherwise
be doing something productive for themselves.
Dude, if Asminold Asminold could make this so much worse,
he could make it like he could make it actually a feature of
the stream. I don't I think this is really not
Is he up to in his in this damn garage? I don't know, man. I
don't think I don't think Asmin Gold is I don't think the community
is like as
psyched about his lifestyle. I maybe I'm wrong. Maybe there's
a channel where they're like, "Look how cool it is for me to
have like all this filth in my house." Maybe that's happening.
I just don't see it. which is to say something bad for everyone
else. Let's hope they all model themselves right at the moment.
Nice. >> To do so is in effect to remove themselves from
real society.
To throw away all potential you might have to affect the rest
of us.
Just think what would the world look like if every reactionary
young man opted into the Asmin Gold lifestyle.
You can't build a civilization out of people like that.
They don't have the skills or the capacity or the knowledge to
shape the future for anyone else.
Which is really good when how they shape the future for others
if they could would be bad.
And one day, Asmin Gold will get himself banned for going too
far or he'll fade out of relevancy or he'll die from living around
piles of garbage or
Yeah, Card doesn't get it, unfortunately. Card's like totally
out to lunch on what the actual criticisms are.
Um, yeah,
I I don't think anybody listens to Asthma Gold that way. I don't
think anybody listens to Asmin Gold and goes, "Yeah, the thing
I'm taking away from this is like that living in garbage is good
and I idealize. I idealize that
I don't idealize I not idolize puts the the lifestyle up as an
ideal. I don't think anybody does that. I think it's crazy."
And all the fans will look around
and realize how much time they've wasted, how much they poisoned
their own minds and how much they let pursuing their own real
material interests.
>> They won't ever realize that. They're like in a trap
that won't >> pass them by completely.
We love to see it, don't we, folks? If you think Asmin Gold or
anyone like him being popular online with young men is cause
for concern,
don't be. It's just something to reflect on. Anyway, once again,
my name's Card. If you might like to hear more from me, feel
free to subscribe to this YouTube page or just take a look at
my other videos.
Card's like proposing that all of these people will wake up from
the spell once the uh once the leader is gone.
I've never seen that work out that way ever. Card is like the
American government right now going like if we this leader in
the Middle East, it'll all be it'll all work. It'll all be stable.
Okay, we just take Gaddafi out, everything will be fine. That's
that's card posting right now
guys. We just got to take we just got to take car we just got
to take Gaddafi out and and everything will be cool,
right? It's like, no, there's obviously the reason that guy's
popular is a commentary on society and you're not going to have
people wake up from that if he continues to be popular. If he's
and he's not doing anything, I think the idea that he get banned.
I think I think the one ban he got cured him of that. We'll see.
But yeah, I just don't see it happening, man. >> Either
way, goodbye for now and have a lovely day. >> Bye.
See you.
Goodbye.